Pleiades a limo feed the father
well assalamualaikum what happened to my
better care to brothers and sisters and
dear friends before I start I want to
praise our lost planet Allah the most
merciful the most just or praises glory
and gratitude belong to Allah subhana WA
Ta'ala for allowing us to bring these
works to you and hope you guys benefit
now before I start the video I want to
make a disclaimer and make it clear for
you guys that anything that I say I want
you guys to understand and assume the
best that never intentionally what I
ever say anything against the Quran and
Sunnah if I do reject my statements now
I want to make one thing clear as well I
believe in refutation and given the seal
to our brothers and sisters in the best
way possible with hikmah with good words
and good manners I believe that
refutation is from the religion and
should be implemented in the correct way
at the right time this is what I believe
now run sisters unfortunately I have
been accused of being selective in who I
advise should I say it for now we use
the word advise instead of saying
reputation because unfortunate a lot of
people Taylor in the negative wait now I
have been accused of this that I'm
advising I choose who to advise and who
not to advise yeah and unfortunately
this is a problem that I realize that a
couple of people are trying it and when
I give us a couple of time I thought
this is an issue now obviously I don't
care what people think about me but you
know the Shaitaan whispers in our ear
and some people have the hard time
assuming the best and that the Prophet
Muhammad peace be upon him when he was
walking with his wife to Sahabi walk
past and you know the Prophet peace of
went up to them and said look this is my
wife and I said oh so lovely we would
never doubt Allah and I'm paraphrasing
we would never doubt that and he said
look the Shaitaan might whisper in your
ear and make you think things that is
not true
so I for is good for me to clarify
myself and shown in this video and also
go through very crucial things that I
truly believe you guys will benefit so
please please please I'm going to keep
our shirts as I can and get on with
inshallah
it is beloved to us to get the Quran and
this from now the narration of the
Prophet peace be upon him as a whole and
execute that by how advising our
brothers and sisters and giving them
mercy to bring them closer to the
religion that is beloved in all of us to
do that - why would we want
even good for us that we'd love for
others what do we want that we would
however unfortunately we have brothers
and sisters who use certain narrations
to bash and attack other people which
has cost and which is caused the
people's hearts to be hardened when it
comes to the matter of advice and
refutation why is it that when today
somebody goes out there to advise a
brother or it might be a refutation for
the sake of the religion it is looked
down upon them is frowned upon the sad
reality is because unfortunately a lot
of people have ended up using this as a
method to click on attack people
unjustly and this is not fair and it's
said that its content because we have
brothers and sisters that the genuine
who have a concern to another problem
you want to come up and advise the
brother or the sister but they are
looked down on from the pond as haraam
police and this is the reason because of
this is because unfortunately when it
comes to advising or refutation some
sisters and brothers are harsh are
aggressive to the person that they want
goodness for which contradicts their
very claim of calling them too good
because it drives the person maybe a bit
further away and another venture is
course is that we have individuals out
there who are calling to falsehood but
because they're doing it in a good nice
manner people are accepting it and this
is a sad reality because we should have
Clark good manners how is it that a
person who cause the falsehood is being
listened to when somebody who comes with
Quran and Sunnah is being rejected this
shows us the brothers and sisters when
doing refutation we have to use hikmah
we have to weigh up the pros and cons we
can't just look at much as black and
white and think you know mm-hmm it's
like this and it has to be done
that is the reason why I'm doing this
video because I have been myself accused
of that and I want to tell you guys why
things are not black and white and I'm
not talking about the religion I want to
make sure of that even though our
religion is perfected and it's clear-cut
however we need to look at the times
that we live in and we are dealing with
different kind of individuals you know
some people some people you have to be a
bit harsh on some people you have to be
a bit soft on some people you don't need
to
advice in public for example you have to
do it in private like no ELISA Lam did
some people have to go and do it in
private some you have to do it in public
it changed we need to weigh out the pros
and cons in the advice of the refutation
that we are about to execute so that is
the reason I want to give you guys an
example some things are not black and
white they're not bad black and white
shall I say now we know we have the
Quran and the Sunnah no problem okay
good
we have many narrations in Quran that
tells us we have to enjoin good and
forbid evil we have to the alles want
Allah says in the Quran let the Rays the
rice amongst you a group of people who
will enjoin good and forbid evil good
that's an evidence that I have to do
that I want also talks of an Australian
how Alice want told them not to fish on
the Sabbath but they acted clever and
put the nets out a day before a day
before the Sabbath so Alice went on the
scholars say that that groove you
disobeyed Allah will enter the fire the
second group that would enter the fire
is because they saw the evil happen in
and they did nothing about it
the third group was obviously the group
that was opposing them as seen fear
Allah don't do this which would enter
Jannah inshallah so the the point here
is the middle group the middle group is
the one neither did they say go and do
it neither they say don't do it but they
were watching and doing nothing about it
so this shows us that we have to do
something when we see an evil taking
place obviously with hikmah and a flock
and good manners yes now the Prophet
peace of him also told told us when you
see evil
try to stop it with your hand if you
cannot do that to try to stop it with
your tongue and if you can't do that
hate in your heart and also there is a
narration with the Prophet peace be upon
him said if you do not enjoin good and
forbid evil our sponsor will send down a
calamity upon your heads that even if
you prostrate to be rejected from you so
now if I get these narrations and this
Quran and Sunnah that I did I say you
know what I have to enjoin a few evil I
have to go and do that now imagine
brothers and sisters I go out on the
street I see a sister who's not dressed
inappropriately and I gotta say Steffie
allah subhanaw taala
you are showing your body parts you
should cover up though you feel Allah
now I'm asking you a question what I
just did that is Haram
it's not Haram the cause I've got on
understood not after I've executed
something that I've heard yeah now I can
move on and then I see a brother who's
got two earring and he's got tight
clothes and I thinking brother why are
you dressed up like a woman why are you
wearing an earring do you feel a loss
upon a metallic come back to you senses
a key have I done anything wrong nope
I've told the brother to fear Allah to
not dress up like a woman wear tight
clothes now I'm walking down into a road
and I see a group of brothers and
sisters in a shisha bus smoking shisha
and free mix in now if I born as a
brother sister told you feel low you
guys a free mix in smoking shisha voice
wrong with you people
I'm advising them I've seen evil I'm
trying to enjoin good and forbid evil
now have I done anything Haram no I
haven't done anything Haram now my plane
comes to this brothers and sisters and
before I mentioned my point when I've
advised that sister was type cloven the
brother with a tight clove and dressed
up like a woman and those businesses in
a shisha bar now if in Tamiya tells us
that when we enjoin good and forbid evil
if the evil is greater we have done no
enjoy like we haven't enjoyed the good
at forbid evil we have cause greater
harm because we have cause for example
listen I was harsh to them or for
example the fact that I'm always doing
that and I'm always on people's cases
has put these group of individuals off
practicing people and then I don't want
another art is gonna come again I've
caused a greater harm so do you see the
matter is not black and white now this
doesn't mean that you don't go and
advise what we're seeing is how is it
the best way that we can do that that's
all I'm saying
like I said at the beginning refutation
is from the religion I don't deny that
now before I move on I want to give one
other example one of one other example
just imagine that I came to the religion
I'm Arif I've come to every religion you
I hear that pictures are Haram you can't
put pictures up
I hear that having a dog is not
permissible
yeah I hear shaking hands with a female
is not permissible
now imagine I go home and uppercut my
pictures throw them on the floor
smashing
kick my dog yeah even though in this
town we believe not to harm any animals
any kind human being I'm just giving
example kick my dog out yeah and then my
cousin cut my femur come shake my hand
of all don't touch my hand yeah now you
need to understand quran and sunnah
teaches me to execute that not like like
for example the basis of how to do it
but how like the hikmah behind it
there's no hikmah so have I really done
anything good or have I driven my family
more away any sound well they're gonna
look at me say you know what this is
what Islam this is what we was fearing
and this is what Islam is done for you
where is the good in what I'm doing so
once again I want to recap we believe in
refutation and it should be done with
hikmah in the right manner with good
manners possible I'm saying and we
should weigh up the pros and cons in
what we are doing and this is my main
main point that is the reason why I am
being accused of being selective on urfu
who do I advise or refute but brothers
and sisters I can't go out there and
refute every Tom Dick and Harry
we have people attacking Islam left
right center for all kind of political
groups to religious groups to even now
fake X Muslims we have got individuals
who are community the religion with the
plan of living it learning a bit of
Arabic to make it seem like they were
legit so we have a group of people
attacking the religion now I need to
really weigh out things as a person
who's in the Dawa scene yeah I need to
weigh the pros and cons when I look at -
Mattin I feel ok there is an individual
who's causing fitna okay is it the right
time a place for me to do that now this
is this is me personally I'm talking
about my soul I'm not talking about any
one I am telling you guys why sometimes
I don't advise every single person yeah
now is it wise for me to leave that off
and then go after this this individual
because if I go upstairs and do there's
going to be another individual
unfortunately there's a lot of Muslims
YouTube's out there that don't do things
the correct weight for me I have an
objective I want to defend this religion
against its enemies
and on some misconception of genuine
non-muslims you want to know about our
religion I want to answer those you
attack
the religion this is I mean the Dow and
this is what I believe that I should be
doing out there now like I said before I
believe in refutation I have no problem
with that and those brothers or sisters
out there who are who want to
specifically make the time about
advising other people may Allah bless
you difficult conversations around what
you're doing do it but all I'm asking is
let there be hey come on let me be
jicama in what we are doing that's all
I'm asking for me I believe there is a
greater goal for me which is to core
people to Islam and answer
misconceptions now guys cue points I'm
gonna mention inshallah and then I'm
gonna finish it cuz I just wanna mean
it's very brief to the point yeah now
some brothers and some sisters live in
this bubble now what do I mean by this
pop yeah
now and I'm not exactly seeing a bubble
to like like you know offend them here
one China sees unfortunately we have a
lot of brothers and sisters who are
religious they are really really I love
bless them and they practice everything
and one line we look up to them we look
up to them and think may Allah you know
with their actions and their sincerity
and shun of makers like them we have
nothing left against that however it's
sad that today don't seem religious
brothers and sisters when they are
practicing for example the brother
practice and where's everything
different the Quran Sunnah
but what's sad is now what they do is
they expect other people to be exactly
like themselves now this is sad why is
sad is because you are now expecting
people to be like EULA for example
mashallah like you when you hear you
obey when a narration comes to you say
you tell me I will obey and may all not
bless you guys but to go out there and
look down and criticize an individual
who is not on the same level with taqwa
that has the same type of level as you
it's sad because unfortunately some
provinces who out there he do vlogs I'll
be an attack brother what you're doing
is unnecessary why are you recording
yourself brothers and sisters if what
they're doing is what they are doing is
not Haram I believe it's a bit unfair to
pick on certain brothers and it's not
understood
let's talk about general people yet Oh
what are you just doing sitting down
it's not nice for you to look down on
another person yes you're religious may
Allah bless you we have no problem with
that but you looking down at another
individual just because he doesn't live
his lifestyle exactly how you do is not
nice it's not nice because you don't
know where you're going to be tomorrow
and you don't know that individual
you're criticizing or - stuff where he's
going to be so that's why it's important
that this little sister should get off
their bubble and understand how to
relate with that youth because you are
thinking the world works how you were
because you're with amongst your group
of sisters and you think that is how we
are and this how everyone should be no
it doesn't work like that you know it
doesn't work like that
and yes you advise another brother or
sister you do it once you do it twice
and maybe three times but you don't go
and insisting and putting a gun to their
head and say no you have to change we
can't do this you know also guys when
advising we should be kind to another
fit another Muslim that were talk to be
kind we should always be kind but when
giving advice we should extra kind look
at Musa al-salaam
when he was ordered to go and speak to
Pharaoh Pharaoh is an individual he was
saying I am your Lord I am your Lord the
biggest sinner this time is [ __ ] this
guy is running around saying I am your
Lord I'm your rub when i'ma sponsor
asked moosa aleihsalaam to go and speak
to pharaoh then I was water said go and
speak in the most harsh way destroy him
Allah said go and speak in kind and
words of hikmah words of hikmah go and
speak with kind words supine Allah today
when were speaking to another Muslim and
advising him we are acting like soup on
Allah we are almost wanted as ordering
moosa aleihsalaam to speak kindness to a
person who's doing the biggest insane I
am your rap I am God we always wanted to
ask you Musa to speak to him in kind
manner today we can't even speak like
that to another believer to another
believer we act like he's our enemy
number one enemy how can we take this
guy out is sad what lie is sad and we
have young team guys
teenagers who've come to the religion
refuting chefs refuting people of
knowledge while I in my brain sometimes
stops and brothers and sisters if I ever
come to you and talk or start refuting
my friends I don't know if I come to you
and start talking about matters that I'm
not be fit to speak about I ask you to
do one thing laugh at me because I'm
telling I'm not a student learn Andhra I
know a lot of brothers who are close to
me they study the religion hamdulillah I
am NOT somebody that I study humble up
but not to the extent where I'm student
knowledge if I come to you with a point
or talking about giving fatwas or
whatever it may be I just ask you to do
two things for me laugh at me at my
video and press the dislike button this
is a sincere advice for myself to you
not to be humble but like I said my job
is to advise the youth and give up down
to the non-muslims and before we call
Bronson solvers are repeated once again
I believe in refutation
I believe that Dean the repetition is
from the religion I believe it should be
done I have no nothing against them all
I'm saying it should be done in the best
way possible and also like I said before
I mentioned my reasons why I choose to
concentrate on matters which I believe
is a bigger important like defending the
religion of a stamp propagating Islam
and answering misconception this is what
I believe refutation like I said before
I have advised people before the
youtubers without sounding arrogant I've
done that before and I am happy to do
that again but if it is necessary and it
needs to be done and with hikmah and
good luck and good months that's all I
ask for
may Allah grant innocent wanted as
general if you have benefited please
share this if we have said anything
wrong like I said before if it's from if
it's outside the forum's from non
rejected from us may Allah grant you
guys general once again and you mr.
Muhammad and you too nice nice jumper
even though I suppress people ice cream
on my today white takes yeah
shoo-shoo shoo-shoo